welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today we are discussing colds
and flu we will talk about what a cold
really is and what a flu really is in
terms of how they impact your brain and
body and of course we will discuss how
to avoid getting colds and flu there are
indeed some excellent science supported
techniques to avoid getting colds and
flu but of course it is impossible to
completely avoid ever getting a colder
flu in your lifetime so we also discuss
how to more quickly get over a colder
flu should you happen to catch one so
during today's discussion I'll talk
about the immune system I'll give you
some mechanistic understanding of how
your immune system works and I promise
to make that discussion accessible to
everybody regardless of whether or not
you have a background in biology and
with that understanding of how your
immune system works you will be in in a
much better position to understand which
tools that is which protocols to
implement should you be exposed to a
colder flu or if you are trying to get
over a cold or flu more quickly than you
would otherwise you'll learn about some
potent behavioral tools for bolstering
your immune system and we will also
discuss various compounds that you might
consider taking to enhance the function
of your immune system to ward off or
treat colds and flu I will also be
dispelling a number of common myths
about treatments for the common cold C
and for the flu there are oh so many
ideas out there about what one could
take or do in order to avoid getting the
colder flu or more quickly get relief
from a colder flu however many of those
are pure myth there's just no sence to
support them and indeed there's some
science that counters those ideas but
the good news is there are indeed
science suppored behavioral protocols
and compounds that one could consider in
order to avoid and treat colds and flu
before we begin I'd like to emphas ize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is ju ju makes medical
grade red light therapy devices now if
there's one thing I've consistently
emphasized on this podcast is the
incredible role that light can have on
our biology and of course I'm always
telling people that they should get some
sunlight in their eyes as soon as
possible after waking on as many days of
their life as possible for sake of
setting circadian rhythm daytime mood
focus and alertness and improve sleep
now in addition to sunlight red light
and nearin red light has been shown to
have positive effects on improving
numerous aspects of cellular and organ
Health including faster Muscle Recovery
improved skin health and wound healing
even improvements in acne or that is
removal of acne reducing pain and
inflammation improving mitochondrial
function and even improving Vision
itself what sets ju apart and why it's
my preferred red light therapy device is
that it has clinically proven
wavelengths meaning it uses specific
wavelengths of red light and near
infrared light in combination that
trigger the optimal seller adaptations
personally I use the handheld ju every
day the handheld ju is about the size of
a thick piece of toast and I also own a
ju panel that allows for full body
exposure and I use that one
approximately five times per week for
about 10 to 15 minutes per session if
you'd like to try ju you can go to ju
spelled
jv.com huberman again that's jv.com
huberman for this month only January
2024 juv is offering exclusive discounts
to huberman lab listeners with up to
$500 off select ju products again that's
ju spell
jv.com huberman to get up to $500 off
select ju products today's episode is
also brought To Us by Helix sleep Helix
sleep makes mattresses and pillows CL
that are tailored to your unique sleep
needs now sleep is the foundation of
mental health physical health and
performance when we are sleeping well
and enough mental health physical health
and performance all stand to be at their
best one of the key things to getting a
great night's sleep is to make sure that
your mattress is tailored to your unique
sleep needs Helix sleep has a brief
two-minute quiz that if you go to their
website you take that quiz and answer
questions such as do you tend to sleep
on your back your side or your stomach
do you tend to run hot or cold in the
middle of the night maybe you don't know
the answers to those questions and
that's fine at the end of that
two-minute quiz they will match you to a
mattress that's ideal for your sleep
needs I sleep on the dusk D mattress and
when I started sleeping on a dusk
mattress about 2 years ago my sleep
immediately improved so if you're
interested in upgrading your mattress go
to helixsleep.com
huberman take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress for you and you'll
get up to $350 off any mattress order
and two free pillows again if interested
go to helixsleep.com huberman for up to
$350 off and two free pillows today's
episode is also brought To Us by Roa Roa
makes eyeglasses and sunglasses that are
the absolute highest quality I've spent
a lifetime working on the biology the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
Roa understands those challenges and has
designed their eyeglasses and sunglasses
accordingly so that you always see with
Crystal Clarity Roa eyeglasses and
sunglasses are designed with a new
technology called float fit which allows
them to fit perfectly and not move
around even when you're active in fact
whenever I'm wearing my Roa eyeglasses
or sunglasses I usually forget that I'm
wearing them I happen to wear Roa
eyeglasses at night when I drive or if
I'm reading at night and I wear Roa
sunglasses during the daytime if it's
very bright especially if I'm driving
into sunlight if you'd like to try Roa
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
roka.com that's
r.com and enter the code huberman for
20% off your first order again that's
r.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout okay let's talk about the
common cold first off no unfortunately
today I cannot tell you the cure for the
common cold because indeed there isn't
one one interesting question however is
why don't we have a cur for the common
cold and the reason is that the cold
virus as it's referred to is actually a
bunch of different viruses some colds
are caused by one what's called serotype
of the virus other colds are caused by a
different serotype of the virus there
are over 160 different types of what
people call the cold virus now cold
viruses fall under an umbrella of a
general category of viruses called Rhino
viruses you can remember that easily
because rhino sounds like Rhino horn the
rhinoceros horn which is of course in
the center of the Rhino's face which is
where your nose is and the cold almost
always causes some degree of nasal
symptoms in humans it's either runny
nose or sneezing or stuffed up nose or
sometimes unfortunately all three now
the reason we don't have a cure for the
common cold is that all of those
different serotypes of the cold virus
mean that the virus itself has a
different shape on its outside and as a
consequence even if you've been exposed
to a cold and you've developed
antibodies against that cold virus the
next cold that comes along very likely
has a different shape and therefore your
body's antibodies to the cold virus it
combed successfully before can't latch
onto and defeat that next different
serotype of the cold virus now a little
later I'll talk about the immune system
and how those different antibodies are
generated but for the time being
understanding that there are a lot of
different types of cold viruses explains
first of all why we don't have a cure
for the common cold but also why you can
get multiple colds within a given year
or even within a given season because
even if you develop antibodies against
one serotype of the cold virus a
different serotype can come along and
you can get sick again with that new
serotype of the cold virus so how do you
catch a cold now one of the problems
with the cold virus being called the
cold virus and the fact that indeed
there are more cold viruses present and
transmitted between humans in the cold
winter months of the year is that people
generally assume that it is the cold
temperatures outside that actually give
you a cold virus and that is simply not
true however what you heard as a kid if
your mom most likely but maybe your dad
said hey don't go outside without a
sweater or jacket on you're going to
catch a cold or you're going to catch
cold you know has ated this uh this myth
that the cold temperatures themselves
are the cause of catching a cold virus
and that's simply not true the virus
that we call the cold virus is spread by
breathing or by sneezing or by people
sneezing or coughing or breathing onto
their hands and then touching surfaces
and then other people touching those
surfaces and then touching most likely
their eyes in order to self- infect now
we're going to get into the details of
how far the virus can spread with a
sneeze how long it can survive on the
hands Etc but for the time being know
this the cold virus is a pretty stable
virus in that it can survive on surfaces
nonhuman or human surfaces meaning skin
or on a table or on a glass or on a door
handle for up to 24 hours so for all you
hypochondriacs out there I probably just
gave you a little spike in cortisol and
for you non- hypochondriacs I hope what
I just said cues you to the fact that
just avoiding people who are sneezing
and coughing is not sufficient to avoid
getting colds and flu However the fact
that a cold virus is Alive and Well on a
given surface let's say on a door handle
does not mean that if you touch that
door handle that you will necessarily be
infected with that cold virus and that's
because your skin actually provides an
excellent barrier against most viruses
and bacteria your skin also includes a
lot of antiviral substances on it even
if you haven't put any of that you know
alcohol stuff or the hand sanitizer
stuff on your skin is a very important
barrier component of your immune system
we're going to talk about that a little
bit later but if somebody has a cold and
they happen to perhaps you know wipe
their nose or sneeze into a tissue
hopefully into a tissue and then discard
that
tissue the cold virus particles are
extremely small how small well most of
us are familiar with thinking about
centimeters or inches if you think about
a millimeter being 1/ 100th of a cmet
well you can take a millimeter and you
can divide that up into a bunch of
little slices also such that you get the
Micron the Micron is 1
1,000th of a centimeter and if you want
to get a sense of how thick or thin that
is the side of a credit card the little
thin side of a credit card is about 200
microns thick so if you set your credit
card flat on a table and then you look
at it from the side that tiny tiny thin
little Edge that's about 200 microns the
cold virus is made up of particles that
are probably in the range of about five
microns or so so it's extremely small I
mean the cold virus therefore with a
good sneeze or even a light sneeze can
spread really far now the good news is
those particles are relatively heavy
they don't tend to mist about in the air
for very long they tend to fall down
onto the ground or onto surfaces but as
I mentioned before they can survive for
a very long time on those surfaces so
should you touch your hand to a door
handle or table or shake the hand of
somebody that has cold virus on their
hands either because they themselves
have a cold or they contacted somebody
else had cold virus and it somehow
landed on their hands just cu the other
person sneeze all these scenarios are
very
realistic that cold virus will not
infect you unless it can get inside of
your body and one of the primary entry
points of it getting inside your body is
via the Eyes by wiping that cold virus
on your eyes now you may think okay I'm
just not going to touch my eyes but a
little bit later we're going to talk
about a study that shows that almost
always indeed almost always when you
meet somebody new you touch your eyes
and the frequency of people touching
their face that is the region of the
face around the eyes and their eyes
throughout the day is extremely high so
this is one of the primary routes by
which the cold virus is transmitted from
one person to the next but of course
there's also the route that we're all
familiar with which is the person that
is sneezing or coughing or blowing their
nose into tissues and then throwing them
in the trash and not washing their hands
after each and every time they do that
so an important aspect of today's
discussion that we will get into once I
also present to you what a flu is and
how it differs from the cold is that
we're going to need to talk about what
stage of infection people are actually
contagious with the colder flu and
there's actually a lot of Mythology
about this in fact there's a lot of just
lying about this people will be coughing
or sneezing and they'll say oh yeah I'm
not contagious any longer or people make
up these things like oh you know if you
had the flu for 2 days then you're no
longer contagious or that you can't be
contagious until you have symptoms so
we're going to go through all the
aspects of contagion and how coughing or
sneezing or how long you've had a cold
or flu actually relates to whether or
not you're contagious in a little bit
but for the time being know that the
cold virus is very very small it can be
transmitted through the air it can be
transmitted via contact from skin to-
skinin contact and it can survive on
surfaces for up to 24 hours and when you
touch those surfaces or a person with
the cold virus most often the way it's
going to get into your body and infect
you such that you get a cold is by
touching your eye region although
touching other regions of your body can
also pass the cold virus into you for
instance the mouth and lips but that's
actually far less common so we'll get
into that in just a little bit now
different serotypes that is different
types of cold virus tend to create a
different array of overall symptoms such
that you know one cold might be a really
quote unquote bad cold others are more
mild some tend to induce more runny nose
others more stuffy head and a little bit
of a fever or in some cases a lot of
fever one thing that's important to
understand is that if people are going
to be infected by the cold virus they
tend to develop symptoms one to two days
after they were exposed to the virus now
the good news is if you are exposed to
the cold virus that doesn't necessarily
mean that you are going to catch that
cold virus that is if your immune system
can fight off that cold even if you've
never been exposed to that serotype
before then you won't actually have that
cold and you won't transmit it so put
differently it is is possible to avoid
getting a cold virus even if you've
never been exposed to that serotype of
cold virus and you happen to come into
contact with somebody who has that
serotype of cold virus or you touch a
surface of some object door handle Etc
that has particular serotype of the cold
virus on it and God forbid you then wipe
your eyes that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to get sick and a good
portion of today's episode is going to
focus on tools that are supported by
science that allow you to bolster your
immune system and greatly increase the
probability that even if you're exposed
to a novel serotype of the cold virus
that is one that's new to you that your
body's never seen before that you won't
get sick another thing to understand
about the cold virus is that you're
generally most contagious to other
people when you feel at your worst that
is when you're coughing and sneezing and
you got the stuffy head watery eyes and
so on but you can also be contagious to
other people when you are starting to
feel better that said most of the data
point to the fact that about 5 to 6 days
after you hit your peak of worst
symptoms or I guess we should say your
Nader the dip of worst symptoms because
it's such an awful state to be in you
are probably exiting the phase in which
you're contagious now I want to be very
clear that does not mean that if you've
had a cold for five or six days that you
are no longer contagious if you continue
to experience sneezing and coughing
watery eyes in the evening you're
feeling much worse first thing in the
morning you're feeling especially groggy
Etc well then you are still contagious
another way to frame this is you know
those people that continue to show up at
the gym and show up at work and they
tell you yeah I got this cold but I've
had it for a few days I'm no longer
contagious and they're wiping their eyes
and they're blowing their nose frankly
they don't know what they're talking
about they are basically a walking
talking breathing sneezing coughing cold
virus Vector a vector is a route for
passage of a virus so please if you are
sneezing if you are coughing if you are
still experiencing the symptoms of a
cold stay home stay away from other
people as much as possible and I realize
that some people simply cannot avoid
going to work or cannot avoid
interacting with other family members or
other people if they have the cold virus
but this mythology that if we've had a
cold for a few days and we're starting
to feel better but we're still
exhibiting symptoms that we're not
contagious that is pure myth it's simply
not grounded in fact now there's nothing
that could be done about that first day
or two after which we're exposed to a
cold virus where we are not not
experiencing symptoms and it's quite
possible to pass the cold virus on to
other people but I think that every
workplace every home environment every
gym every society would benefit greatly
if people who were sick with the cold
did not expose other people to that cold
virus as much as possible and indeed
this is a serious issue it's not just
about a few sniffles and watery eyes
there's an enormous financial and mental
health cost and physical health cost to
people getting the cold and it's not
just about people who are immune
compromised or elderly people what we're
generally referring to as the cold today
can be mild it can be moderate it can
also be very severe and it can
exacerbate other health issues that
people have and we'll talk about that a
little bit later and how to offset some
of those health issues okay so now let's
talk about the flu virus the flu virus
is as I mentioned a virus and just like
with the cold there are different
serotypes of the flu virus there are
also different General categories of flu
virus so you've got your a type flu
viruses your B type type flu viruses and
your C type flu viruses and by the way
I'm saying flu viruses but of course I'm
referring to influenza but it's just
kind of Common Place nowadays to refer
to influenza as the flu similar to cold
viruses the different types of flu
viruses exist based on the different
types of proteins that they express on
their surface in fact in the news over
the last few years there have been a
number of different flu virus strains
that have been described according to
their surface protein character istics
things like the H1N1 virus what is H1N1
H1N1 describes the different types of
proteins that are expressed on the
surface of that particular flu virus now
the most common type of flu viruses are
in that a category of flu this is the
type of flu that caused the Spanish flu
now the Spanish Flu which by the way did
not originate in Spain people think it
probably originated in New York or
perhaps elsewhere but certainly not in
Spain killed anywhere from 17 to 50
million people depending on which
literature you read that's an enormous
number of people and it occurred in four
different waves of infection that
occurred between the years 1918 and 1920
the Spanish Flu was a type A H1N1 virus
and actually it's worth noting that this
winter season there have been some cases
of H1N1 already reported in the United
States and elsewhere now of course the
goal is always to contain the
propagation of those flu viruses and
that is done through a number of
different approaches the best and most
reliable approach of course is to not
come into contact with somebody that is
carrying the H1N1 or any other type of
flu virus however based on the way that
the flu virus infects the body the way
that the symptoms emerge and the ways
that viruses propagate that can't always
be avoided one thing to know and I
consider this a fortunate aspect of flu
virus biology is that the flu virus
unlike the cold virus can only exist on
surfaces for for about 2 hours after
about 2 hours it tends to die off so the
flu virus is most typically passed by
human human contact or coming into
contact that is walking into a cloud of
somebody's sneeze that contains flu
virus or somebody's cough that contains
flu virus and yes it is possible that
shaking someone's hand could actually
introduce flu virus to your hand and
then if you wipe your eyes or I'll talk
about a few other portals of entry for
the flu virus and cold virus in a few
minutes can get into your body and
infect you and yet you can pick up the
flu virus from surfaces however that is
far less common than the flu virus
passing from human human contact now
there aren't as many different types of
flu virus as there are types of cold
virus and that's why there have been
attempts at making flu vaccines or
so-called flu shots I think most people
are familiar with the signs and
advertisements online and in the
workplace and school saying you know get
your flu shot this season the reason
that flu shots can exist at all is
because there are limited enough types
of flu virus present in a given year
that specific vaccines that is flu shots
can be generated against that particular
strain of the flu virus so how effective
is the flu shot and I want to be very
specific here when we say the flu shot
singular it sort of implies that there's
one flu shot that can combat all the
different types of flu and as you just
learned that is not the case so we
probably should be saying the flu shots
but just for sake of Simplicity when I
say the flu shot I mean the flu shot
that's given in a given flu season that
is directed at specific strains of the
flu because researchers have determined
that that particular strain of flu or
strains of flu are the ones that are
most abundant for that particular flu
season Studies have shown that getting
the flu shot reduces one's risk of
Contracting the particular flu that is
most abundant That season by about 40 to
60% but of course the flu shot is
completely ineffective at combating any
other forms of the flu virus and of
course colds or other types of upper
respiratory infections Studies have also
shown that taking the flu shot can
reduce the severity of one's symptoms if
they in fact get the flu anyway now
personally I don't typically get the flu
shot and the reason for that is that I
don't tend to go into environments where
I am particularly susceptible to getting
the flu I don't work in a hospital or
clinic I don't tend to interact with
large numbers of people on a daily basis
so for me I've opted not to get the flu
shot now that doesn't mean that I've
never contracted the flu as I mentioned
earlier I tend to get sick with a cold
or flu about once every 18 to 24 months
and the severity of that cold or flu has
ranged from you know at one point a very
high fever in one case but typically a
moderate fever and the usual symptoms of
malaise that we've been discussing and
I've managed to get over those without
having taken the flu shop pretty easily
now of course we also don't know that
those were actually flu despite the
distinct differences between the
symptoms of Cold and Flu most people
don't really know whether or not they
have a cold or flu so this is another
thing to think about when considering
whether or not to get the flu shot
ultimately because at least to my
knowledge most workplaces do not mandate
that people get the flu shot I could be
wrong about certain workplaces but my
experience is that most workplaces do
not mandate that people get the flu shot
when you take the flu shot you're really
hedging a bet you're hedging a bet
against the fact that you will be or not
be exposed to that particular strain of
flu virus that's most abundant That
season or strains of flu virus that are
most abundant That season and that the
flu shot that you're taking is directed
at those particular strains so again in
my case I don't tend to take the flu
shot but of course you need to make the
decision that's right for you for
instance if you have family members that
are immune compromised or you work in a
school or you think that you are exposed
to a lot of flu or you're concerned
about transmitting flu to any one
individual or group of individuals those
are all things that need to be taken
into consideration and of course speak
to your physician I will also say this
which is that I mentioned that I've
tended to catch colds or flu at a rate
of about once every 18 to 24 months and
when I say a cold or flu I mean a
serious one one that keeps me in bed
where I have a fever and I'm sweating
what I have done and I continue to do is
because I pay pretty close attention to
how well I'm sleeping or different life
events my different workouts Etc and I
put those into my calendar and I have a
short hand to do that so it only takes
about 30 seconds each day okay did this
work out it was kind of level seven out
of 10 intensity got good sleep last
night or poor sleep in know what good in
poor sleep is for me I mean that's about
the level that I'm charting these things
I have been able to go back and look at
the events preceding when I've come down
with a cold or flu again I don't know
whether or not it was a cold or a flu
but before I got sick and I have seen
for instance if I've ever done two hard
workouts in a day something I never do
any longer I've tended to get sick after
that if I've tended to do hard workouts
and then expose myself to cold
temperatures while traveling especially
traveling overseas that tended to
precede those colds or flu which again
for me are very seldom so it's a limited
data set this is entirely anic data
meaning related to my own history of
getting colds and flu but it's something
that I actually recommend people do
which is you know to pay attention to
when you first started getting symptoms
pay attention to when you got over a
given what you think is a colder flu and
then to look at what was happening in
the days before in that day I don't
think it's possible to do hyper precise
forensics on a colder flu right I mean
you could have gone into to the gas
station put your credit card in the
machine to you know grab a drink out of
the refrigerator and picked up a colder
flu from the handle of the refrigerator
or from the credit card machine or even
from the gas pump you simply don't know
however if you look at the pattern of
behavior travel sleep exercise sorts of
interactions you were having prior to
getting a bad cold or flu chances are
you're going to learn something
interesting and be able to avoid getting
a serious cold or flu at least to some
extent going forward and I've done that
I think fairly successful y because I
can tell you that the frequency or colds
or flu that I've come down with has
indeed been dropping from year to year
so where're as a decade ago I tended to
get colds or flu probably about once a
year and in some cases even twice a year
although that was pretty rare that
really expanded to about once every 18
months and then in the last five years I
think I've gotten sick uh two times
pretty badly with a colder flu and then
once with a kind of mild colder flu so I
tell you all that just as an example of
how you can start to think about how
your immune system interacts with
different types of behaviors different
types of situations such that you can
learn something about your immune system
and what's going to best protect you
against getting colds and flu going
forward which of course is a great thing
to do because we all think that we can
get out there be around people that are
coughing and sneezing we can go to the
gym when it's crowded and winter oh that
person over there is you know coughing
but I'm going to just you know stay a
few feet away no big deal and while I
don't want to turn anyone into
hypochondriacs that's how you get
infected that's how you get a colder
fluid and at the same time I don't think
anyone should you know get to the point
where they're afraid to go into a gym or
afraid to go to the workplace but I will
say once again if you're sick with a
colder flu if you are coughing sneezing
blowing your nose runny eyes and you're
walking into work or the gym or onto
public transportation and you're telling
people I'm not contagious you're lying
I'd like to take a brief moment and
thank one of our sponsors and that's ag1
ag1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that also contains adaptogens I started
taking ag1 way back in 2012 the reason I
started taking it and the reason I still
take it every day is that it ensures
that I meet all of my quotas for
vitamins and minerals and it ensures
that I get enough Prebiotic and
probiotic to support gut health now gut
health is something that over the last
10 years we realized is not just
important for the health of our gut but
also for our immune system and for the
production of neurotransmitters and
neuromodulators things like dopamine and
serotonin in other words gut health is
critical for proper brain functioning
now of course I strive to consume
healthy Whole Foods for the majority of
my nutritional intake every single day
but there are a number of things in ag1
including specific micronutrients that
are hard to get from Whole Foods or at
least in sufficient quantities so ag1
allows me to get the vitamins and
minerals that I need probiotics
prebiotics the adaptogens and critical
micronutrients so anytime somebody asks
me if they were to take Just One
supplement what that supplement should
be I tell them ag1 because ag1 supports
so many different systems within the
body that are involved in mental health
physical health and performance to try
ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman and
you'll get a year supply of vitamin D3
K2 and five free travel packs of ag1
again that's drink a1.com
huberman now the Diabolical thing about
the flu virus is that just like the
Diabolical thing about the cold virus
you start shedding virus that is you are
contagious about 24 hours prior to the
onset of first symptoms for you so that
means that you can be a flu viral Vector
even when you aren't having symptoms
that's just the unfortunate aspect of
these viruses they're very clever they
don't have brains but these viruses have
adapted to propagate from host to host
to host they have a drive to continue to
stay alive and to infect more host so
even though they don't have a brain they
have a sort of uh let's call it viral
intelligence and as I've said several
times now if you are still exhibiting
symptoms of the colder flu you are
contagious however with respect to the
flu you are most contagious during the
three days when you feel the absolute
worst when your fever is at its worst
we'll talk about how to deal with fever
a little bit later when you are coughing
and sneezing headache all of that when
that is at its peak that is when you are
most contagious so again I realize that
people can't always avoid contact with
other people you know you live under the
same roof sometimes caretaker is
interacting with the person that has the
cold or flu and I do want to remind you
something I said earlier which is just
because you come into contact with a
colder flu does not necessarily mean
that you will come down with that is be
infected by a colder flu whether or not
you come down with a colder flu is of
course dependent on whether or not you
come into contact with it you can't
catch a cold or flu that you've never
come into contact with just like you
can't get eaten by a shark if you never
go in the ocean however the probability
of coming down with that cold or flu of
it getting past your immune system
barriers and infecting you is going to
be strongly dictated by the different
aspects of your immune system for which
there are three major aspects which
we'll talk about next and of course the
things that you do to bolster those
three aspects of your immune system okay
let's talk about your immune system and
I have to confess that even though I've
spent well over three decades being a
student of and a researcher of the
nervous system the immune system is oh
so cool and I say that because it has
this incredible elegance and logic to it
it basically consists of three major
lines of Defense there's a physical
barrier or rather a set of physical
barriers that exist between the organs
of your body and the outside world and
you're probably immediately thinking
skin and yes indeed it includes your
skin but also some interesting things
like the mucosal lining of your nose and
mouth and even some of the liquids that
are on the surface of your eyes we'll
talk about those in a moment then
there's a second line of defense which
is for any virus or bacteria or fungus
for that matter but today we're talking
about viruses colds and flu viruses any
viruses that get past the physical
barrier of your skin and the mucosal
lining of particular regions of your
body well then you have What's called
the innate immune system the innate
immune system is this very generalized
response system it's General in the
sense that it deploys a basic set of
neurochemicals that are not specific to
the particular virus that's made it into
your body so not only is it not specific
to a particular serotype of the cold or
a different type of flu virus but it's
not even discriminating between cold or
flu virus this thing we call the innate
immune system is a generalized response
system to go and combat viruses so it
could be a cold it could be a flu it
could be a bacteria it could be a fungus
it could even be a physical object and
your innate immune system responds by
saying okay let's go deal with this now
the third component of your immune
system is What's called the Adaptive
immune system and I alluded to this
aspect of your immune system a little
bit earlier the Adaptive immune system
is the aspect of your immune system that
recognizes because the innate immune
system told it that something has
infected the body at some level at some
organ or set of organs and there's an
emergency and the Adaptive immune system
goes in and in a very targeted way
figures out what sorts of proteins it
needs to produce that is antibodies to
combat that specific serotype of virus
okay so the immune system has a physical
barrier component and it's not just skin
some other things as well you've got
your innate immune system which is this
generalized response system and then
there's the Adaptive immune system let's
talk about the physical barrier
component first and this is actually a
good opportunity for us to just take a
brief step back and realize that anytime
we're talking about our physiology
there's going to be a mechanical set of
features and there's going to be a
chemical set of features so right now
we're talking about the immune system
and the mechanical feature or the
physical feature of the immune system is
this barrier between the organs of our
body and the outside world and the most
obvious of those is the skin you are
contained in this bag of stuff that we
call skin the skin isn't just for
putting clothing on and for adorning
with jewelry or tattoos if that's your
thing watches Etc your skin is a living
organ in and of itself I think we're
most accustomed to think about the heart
and the lungs and the liver and the
Brain as organs of the body but the skin
is an organ of the body as well it has a
bunch of different layers of cells from
the outside to the inside actually the
skin cells themselves are made in the
deeper layers of the skin and they
migrate out towards the surface of the
skin and at the surface of the skin on
top of those cells and made by those
cells are different types of chemicals
that actually serve as antibacterial and
antiviral agents meaning if a cold virus
or flu virus or other type of virus
lands on the skin it can neutralize and
kill that virus so your skin is a very
important physical barrier against
viruses such as the cold or flu virus
getting into your body and infecting
other cells and tissues now your skin is
not contigous meaning there are holes in
it so let's think about those holes for
a second as we go from head to foot it's
pretty obvious that your eyes have these
two openings and those are openings in
your skin right as you open your eyelids
beneath there are your corneas the shiny
part of your eyes and a little bit
further back at the back inner lining of
your eyeball you have a very thin three
cell layer thick piece of tissue that we
call the neural retina and I say this
because the neural retina is actually a
piece of your brain so you have two
pieces of brain that line the back of
your eyes and that's the light sensing
tissue in the back of your eyes now I
say this because what this means is that
it's a very short distance between the
opening of your skin that we call your
eyelids and your brain now most of the
brain of course is contained in the
cranial Vault within what most people
call the skull but your brain isn't far
away from those openings that we call
your eyelids so as a consequence on the
surface of your eyes those corneas the
shiny part of your eyes on the outside
there are a bunch of different chemical
features there are tears that are made
by your lacrimal glands but there also a
lot of antibacterial agents that
actively kill off stuff that could
potentially infect your body could make
it into your body maybe even into your
brain if you've ever woken up in the
morning and you have some crust on your
eyes and you look at that crust that
kind of yellowy stuff sometimes it's
yellow I know this is kind of gross
that's actually dead bacteria that your
eyes have successfully defeated during
your night's sleep so when you wipe
those away you're taking the casualties
of a war that you won during your
night's sleep and you're whisking those
away now as we descend a little bit
further down the face they're of course
the nostril openings and the nostril
openings tend to be kind of sticky right
they're moist sticky and warm right you
don't have to put your fingers up them
right now you just know they're moist
sticky and warm get your fingers out of
your nose please the mucosal lining of
your nose is actually a very important
substance that is sticky in order to
trap viruses such as colds and flu
viruses and then chemical components
within the mucosa lining can neutralize
them that's the best case scenario there
are of course scenarios in which the
cold or flu virus takes residence in
your mucosal lining and can make its way
back into your sinus passages and can
then infect other cells and tissues of
your body because the virus replicates
and spreads throughout the body and then
going a a little bit further down I
realize this is obvious you have your
mouth and what's really interesting is
that your mouth also has mucosal lining
which is sticky and it has chemical
components to neutralize incoming
viruses but we know that the type of
mucus and the type of bacteria that live
in your nose and mouth that by the way
are very healthy for you and encourage
healthy immune system function that is
act as ways to neutralize viruses within
your nose and mouth are very different
so your nose and your mouth may seem
similar at the level of okay well it's
warm and sticky in there there's mucus
but they are very very different tissues
in fact if you think about your mouth
it's this incredible structure that not
only lets you eat and breathe in and out
through although I suggest most people
be nasal breathers for most of the time
of their day and night if you can of
course sometimes you have to mouth
breathe but keep this in mind that you
have this big opening in the front of
your face and bacteria are getting in
there all day long viruses are getting
in there all day long and in most cases
you are successfully combating those
viruses and bacteria because the mucosal
lining of your mouth and your nose for
that matter and the microbiota those
little micro organisms that have taken
resonance in your nose and mouth are
helping to contribute to fight off
bacteria and viruses provided the
microbiota there are diverse and are of
the type you want which we'll talk a
little bit more about later and then
descending further down the body of
course there are other openings Into
Your Skin Barrier namely the urethra of
the penis or vagina and of course the
vaginal Canal so the genitals of course
have their own mucosal lining and as you
can imagine it is distinct in terms of
its physical makeup and its chemical
makeup from the mucosal lining of your
nasal passages and mouth and then of
course we have the rectum and anus which
is the outflow pathway of your
intestines which are
post-design and frankly there need to be
more data in order to really resolve
this but it seems like the primary entry
site for viruses to get into the body
tends to be the eyes or the mouth and we
can get into some of the reasons why
that would be so but if you think back
to our conversation about the way that
colds and flu exist in the world either
as aerosols or on surfaces of objects or
on surfaces of skin well then what I'm
about to tell you next will make it oh
so obvious why the eyes and the mouth
are the primary sites of for colds and
flu and if you keep that in mind there's
a good chance you can avoid a lot of
colds or flu that you would otherwise
catch okay so before I talk about the
important roles of the innate and the
Adaptive immune system in keeping colds
and flu at Bay I'll tell you that you
have a problem and that problem is that
you tend to touch your eyes very often
in fact you tend to touch your eyes most
often after you shook somebody else's
hand now why am I picking on you well in
fact I'm not I'm picking on all of you
and I'm picking on myself included
because there have been several studies
now primarily from Noam soel Lab at The
whitesman Institute showing that when
people encounter another person and they
shake their hand they either touch their
eyes or touch another region of their
face very close to the eyes or that they
touched their hand to their mouth now
there are a bunch of theories as to why
people do this there's the idea that
people are actually sniffing their own
hands
and in particular sniffing their own
hand more often after they Shake someone
else's hand as a way to detect what
chemo signals exist on the other person
not necessarily conscious smelling of
the other person's smell but rather some
sort of unconscious mechanism by which
we take the chemicals of the person we
come into contact with and we bring them
to our nose our eyes or in some cases
our upper lip and that our olfactory
system that is the neurons that exist
just behind the back of our nose are
processing that information and getting
all sorts of important information about
how stressed the other person is their
hormones uh whether or not we recognize
them the fact that they are different
from us that's right we are also
smelling ourselves all day long noom's
lab has shown this that people are kind
of walking around in their own odor
Cloud we tend to touch our armpits we
tend to touch different aspects of our
body yes and smell ourselves multiple
times throughout the day this is all
being done unconsciously I suppose some
people are doing it consciously and that
there's a lot of information about our
physiology and health and when we do
this after shaking somebody's hand that
there's a lot of information about the
other person's physiology and health
that our nervous system our factory
system and deep parts of our brain that
are involved in primitive type behaviors
but also some pretty sophisticated
behaviors are taking into account now
Noom soel was a guest on the hubin Lab
podcast I encourage you to check out
that episode if you have time it's a
fascinating Voyage into the olfactory
system and not just conscious smelling
or sniffing of things so we go oh that
smells good or that smells bad or that
person you know is somebody I want to
mate with or hang out with or avoid it's
also unconscious processing of so-called
chemo signals chemical signals but the
reason I'm bring up these studies now in
the context of colds and flu and how to
avoid getting colds and flu is as a
reminder that we are pretty much wired
to contact our own face with our own
hands at the level of our eyes nose and
upper lip and around the eyes very
shortly after we touch somebody else's
skin and if you are mindful of it you
can actually avoid bringing colds or flu
to your face now in doing so are you're
going to shortcircuit a bunch of other
important biological processes involved
in understanding what's going on in your
environment because you're not bringing
in those smells I suppose that's
possible but with respect to avoiding
colds and flu it seems like a pretty
good trade-off to me so the point that
I'm trying to make here is that in order
for you to catch a cold or flu that cold
or flu virus the little particles of
cold and flu virus need to make it into
your body and the primary entry sites
are eyes nose mouth and the primary
actions by which we bring colds and flu
viruses to our eyes nose mouth are by
touching other people or by touching
other surfaces that have colder flu
virus just to remind you cold virus can
exist up to 24 hours on a given surface
flu virus tends to die off after about 2
hours on a given surface and we're
bringing to our face we are literally
bringing the virus to ourselves so a
little bit more conscious awareness
about that fact means that you can
probably avoid colds and flu to some
extent how much well it's unclear it's
unclear because as you recall some
people have and are passing along cold
or flu virus prior to any symptoms and
of course it's possible that you can
walk into an aerosol cloud of cold or
flu virus even if a person isn't there
and you don't come into contact with
them but some conscious awareness of
these routes of path passage for the
colder flu virus I do believe can reduce
the probability that you will catch a
colder flu and of course I'm not
encouraging people to never touch touch
is an important part of social
connection and social bonding but if you
start to think about these portals of
entry for the cold and flu virus into
your body well then you you know perhaps
might think twice before you know
hugging someone kissing them on the
cheek during a time in which you're
trying to actively avoid getting the
cold or flu now I feel a little bit
funny about sharing this information
because again I don't want to encourage
will always be at you know arms distance
you know uh you know fake fist bumping
you know keeping a gap between them
again touch is an important component of
social connection but since today's
topic is colds and flu and how to avoid
getting colds and flu just like you
can't get eaten by a shark if you don't
go in the ocean there's a much lower
probability that you're going to get a
colder flu if you're not touching a lot
of hands and bringing those hands to
your eyes nose or mouth I suppose one
way around the sort of do I hug do I
shake hands thing is to just be
conscious of the fact that when you
shake somebody's hand that you're very
likely to touch your eyes or face within
the next 30 seconds or so and maybe you
end up being that person who puts some
hand sanitizer on your hands sometimes
that can feel a little awkward to do
that right in front of somebody you know
it's kind of sending a signal like hey I
don't want you to infect me but guess
what you don't want them to infect you
okay let's imagine that a cold or flu
virus makes it into your system it
breaches the physical barrier of your
skin and mucosal lining now you have in
mind all the different ways that could
happen and all the different ways that
could be prevented but we are starting
at a point here a hypothetical point
whereby that colder flu virus has made
it into your body your immune system has
an absolutely exquisitely sophisticated
way of knowing you versus other meaning
cells within your body that are of you
and cells of your body that are from
other organisms or viruses from the
outside world and when viruses such as a
cold or flu virus are detected in your
body your body might not even recognize
that it's a cold or flu virus it might
not even recognize that it's a virus at
all it just knows that this thing that's
in me is of other it's not me I've never
seen it before this is not me these are
not my cells these are not the chemicals
that I'm producing and your immune
system is amazing in that way and when
it occurs your innate immune system
launches a response what is that
response well first of all the response
is very rapid right colder flu makes it
into your body and your innate immune
system immediately or near immediately
launches an attack on that Invader or
Invaders because as soon as the virus
gets into your body it's going to start
replicating as quickly as it
can what
happens white blood
cells that your body produces will go to
the sites where those viruses are and
the by the way those viruses are
basically getting into cells of your
body and then hijacking the genetic
Machinery of those cells in order to
replicate within those cells and then
exit those cells and then go infect more
cells that's how these viruses work your
body's making white blood cells things
like neutrophils natural killer cells
macras these are what we call affector
cells that act as a kind of ambulance
system and go to the sites that those
viruses exist and the cells that they've
infected and start trying to physically
barrier them in and also use specific
chemical mechanisms to neutralize and
kill those viruses again anytime you're
think about biology think mechanical
features and chemical features of a
response now a key component of the
innate immune system is What's called
the complement system not complement
like oh you look very nice today but
complement okay the complement system
which exists in the plasma within your
blood these are chemicals in your
bloodstream that go and Mark specific
cells that have been infected or viruses
with a signal a chemical signal that
essentially looks like an eat me signal
to these other cell types of your immune
system such that those natural killer
cells go through the body and go looking
for the cells that have this eat me
signal on them and try and destroy those
particular cells the other thing that
urinate immune system does is that the
cells that have been infected and that
are undergoing damage remember they have
colder flu virus within them and they're
hijacking the cell or Machinery of those
cells and using it to produce their own
virus more of the virus and as a
consequence the genetic Machinery of
those cells is not able to do a bunch of
other things that it normally can do or
at least not as well well those cells
that are really hurting release a help
me signal and then in response to that
help me signal your immune system
releases what are called cyto kindes
things like interlukin 1 interlan 6
tumor necrosis Factor Alpha just fancy
nerd names for different types of
molecules that go to the site of
infection and try to help or assist to
remove that infection and they also Tred
to assist the repair of the cells that
have been infected by those viruses now
one of the mechanical or physical
consequences of these chemical signals
like Incan 1 Incan 6 tnf Alpha again
those are all cyto kindes being drawn to
a particular cell or region of cells
that have been infected is that it
creates some physical swelling of the
area it impacts the vasculature the
veins and capillaries that feed that
area and in response to they put more
blood there so you get some swelling or
you'll get in some cases the release of
histamines right we think of
anti-histamine drugs well histamines are
an aspect of your immune system they
move around in your body in these really
cool cells called masted cells Mas mass
cells and when the histamines are
released that area becomes kind of hot
and swelling it's what we call edema and
that whole area is marked as really a
sight just like a crash site on the side
of the road it's like hey we've got eat
me signals to get the debris and the bad
stuff out of here try to get those
viruses out of here we've got help me
signals to try and help the injured
cells just like you would try and help
people at a car crash and there's a
bunch of swelling so there's additional
blood flow sometimes there's some other
physical features as well now the
important thing to know is that the
innate immune system is very fast and it
is agnostic to the type of infection in
fact it doesn't even matter if it's a
bacterial physical fungal or viral
infection but it certainly isn't paying
attention to the exact serotype of cold
virus or whether or not it's an H1
influenza or another type of influenza
so way to think about the innate immune
system is that it is a very fast and
non-specific response to a viral or
other type of Invader now that's all a
bunch of biology but if you think about
it let's imagine a scenario where you go
to a party hang out the party you don't
see anyone coughing or sneezing but
maybe one person there has a cold virus
or they have a flu virus and they aren't
even aware of it they're not going to
come down with symptoms for another day
or so you talk to that person you shake
hands maybe touch your eyes maybe you
don't but you're exposed to that colder
flue virus you go home you go to sleep
you wake up the next morning you feel
fine and then sometime in the next
afternoon you know you start to feel a
little tickle in your throat or you
start to feel just a little bit of
fatigue or
malaise do you have that colder flu well
possibly okay we don't know for sure but
assuming that that cold or flu virus did
indeed make it into your system then
your immune system is starting to create
a set of responses that we talked about
a moment ago but it also tends to impact
things at the level of your brain such
that you kind of feel like you know I
don't feel quite right I feel like a
little bit I don't feel great and there
are a lot of reasons why you would feel
that way and we'll talk about those
reasons a little bit later but does that
mean that you're necessarily coming down
with a colder flu well technically yes
your inate immune system is deployed to
fight this foreign viral Invader but
whether or not you actually get a
full-blown cold or flu or put
differently how severe that cold or flu
infection is depends depends on whether
or not your innate immune system can
fight off that colder flu at the outset
and indeed there are many cases we
believe where you get exposed to a
colder flu it makes it into your body
but your innate immune system is
sufficient to beat it to fight it back
this is one of the reasons why it's so
important that if you're starting to
feel a bit under the weather and you
think you're coming down with a colder
flu that you do certain things in order
to make sure that your innate immune
system is both ready and that it can
launch a fullscale attack on that colder
flu virus we're going to talk about how
to do that a little bit later I'm not
trying to withhold it's just it's
important to understand that just
because the virus makes it into your
body doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to get a full-blown cold or
flu and in fact that inate immune system
sometimes is sufficient to prevent that
colder flu from replicating enough that
you get the full-blown set of symptoms
and that's kind of an ideal scenario so
we're definitely going to talk today
about what to do if you start to feel a
little bit of malaise what to do if you
just discover that oh you know that
person I was hanging out with at the
party the night before they're really
sick with a colder flu because there are
things you can do to increase the
probability that your innate immune
system can handle the battle
sufficiently such that you never have to
get to the next component of the immune
response which is the Adaptive immune
response I'd like to take a quick break
and thank our sponsor insid tracker
insid tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals now I've long
been a believer in getting regular blood
work done for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact your
immediate and long-term Health can only
be analyzed from a quality blood test
now a major problem with a lot of blood
tests out there however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
make it very easy because they have a
personalized platform that allows you to
see the levels of all those things
metabolic factors lipids hormones Etc
but it gives you specific directives
that you can follow that relate to
nutrition behavioral modifications
supplements Etc that can help you bring
those numbers into the ranges that are
optimal for you if you'd like to try
insid tracker you can go to insid
tracker.com huberman to get 20% off any
of insid tracker's plans again that's
insidetracker
tocomin okay so the third layer of your
immune system is your adaptive immune
system and this is an amazing aspect of
you okay the stuff we talked about up
until now the physical barrier the
innate immune system so so cool but the
Adaptive immune system is really a
mindblower the most important thing to
understand about your adaptive immune
system is that as the name suggests its
job is to create antibodies specific to
the very Intruder that made it into you
and infected your cells the very
specific serotype of cold virus the very
specific type of influenza such that you
defeat that virus but then in an amazing
way your adaptive immune system also
maintains a memory of that battle and
keeps within your body believe it or not
within a population of stem cells which
are cells that can rise to more cells
such that if you ever encounter that
same serotype of cold virus or same
strain of influenza again that your
antibodies can immediately neutralize
that colder flu virus the Adaptive
immune system has the ability to make
proteins that have a particular shape on
their surface that matches the shape of
the thing that your immune system is
trying to kill now the Adaptive immune
system has two basic phases in the first
phase the Adaptive immune system makes
these things called
immunoglobulins IGS and the
immunoglobulins come in different forms
there's IGG there's IGM there are other
types of IGS as well for sake of today's
discussion know that the initial
wave of antibodies that the Adaptive
immune system makes or of the IGM
variety and the IG antibodies can travel
to and latch on to the surface of the
colder flu virus and it matches it
pretty well it's not perfect but it
matches it pretty well think about uh
for instance a particular serotype of
cold virus or the H1N1 flu virus having
you know very particular Contour on its
surface the M approximates that Contour
such that it's better at fighting that
colder flu virus than is the innate
immune system but it's not a perfect fit
however the Adaptive immune system
doesn't stop with the production of
those igms the Adaptive immune system
takes that information about how precise
or imprecise that fit is between the IGM
antibodies and the surface of that
particular cold or flu virus and then in
an amazing way send signals back to the
stem cell populations in the bone marrow
and other tissues and then more
antibodies come out of the IGG variety
and the IG proteins are very specific to
the shape of that particular cold virus
or flu virus such that the Iggs then can
Define to and neutralize those viral
particles okay so when we talk about the
immune system we're talking about a
physical barrier that if it is
breached a cold or flu virus takes
residence and starts to replicate the
innate immune system launches a
generalized attack on that colder flu
virus and then the Adaptive immune
system kicks in usually a couple days
later first with the production of
antibodies that are pretty specific to
the particular virus that happened to
make it into the body and infect cells
but then there's a second wave of
production of antibodies and those
antibodies are incredibly specific for
that particular cold or flu virus and as
I mentioned earlier the Adaptive immune
system then acquires a memory of the
specific fit between a given antibody
that it made and the viral Invader and
the successful battle that those
antibodies waged on that Viral Invader
and that memory is maintained such that
if the next week or the next season you
encounter the exact same serotype of
cold virus or same type of flu virus
well then you already have antibodies
ready to be deployed sometimes the
antibodies continue to circulate in your
system sometimes you need to generate
more of them and the immune system is
that amazing it can actually send a
message back to that stem cell
population in the bone marrow or
elsewhere say Hey listen this virus that
we beat a few weeks or months or years
back it's back we need more antibodies
and boom your adaptive immune system
churns those antibodies out and kills
the virus now as a final point about the
immune system I've been talking a lot
today about cells traveling to and
killing viruses and sending signals eat
me help me Etc it's important to
understand that while cells can migrate
through the the body a lot of what we're
talking about here is the movement of
proteins through the vascular through
the blood system of the body but there's
another system that's very important for
all of this that's collaborating with
the vascular system and that's the
lymphatic system we don't have time to
go into a whole lecture about the
lymphatic system but suffice to say the
lymphatic system can pull stuff from the
blood such as viruses but also cells
that have been beaten up or cells that
have been eaten and are contained within
other cells such as macrofagos and it
can do some filtering of those different
cell types and it can produce its own
useful chemicals that then can be
reintroduced to the bloodstream in order
to help combat the infection now this
becomes very important when later we
talk about how specific forms
intensities and durations of exercise
can increase the ability for your innate
immune system to combat infections so
that your adaptive immune system perhaps
doesn't even have to get involved in the
battle because your innate system
handled it there are data to show the
exercise of sufficient intensity and
duration but not excessive intensity and
duration can recruit the lymphatic
system and recruit or increase the
activity of the innate immune system
even in the absence of an infection such
that if you go to that party and you
encounter that person with a colder flu
you can defeat that colder flu virus at
the outset and never have to deal with
making antibodies to that colder flu
virus at all okay so now you have a
fairly sophisticated biological
understanding of what colds are what flu
are and the way that immune system works
to fight off viruses like colds and flu
so with that in mind I think now is the
appropriate time to start talking about
what the scientific peer-reviewed
research says about how to allow your
immune system to function at its best
such that you can combat colds and flu
meaning if you are exposed to a cold or
flu that is if it breaches that physical
barrier of your skin and the mucosal
lining of your nose your mouth or it
gets into your eyes that you stand the
greatest chance of defeating that colder
flu at the the level of your innate
immune system such that your adaptive
immune system never even has to respond
to it by creating all those specific
antibodies now fortunately there are a
lot of different things we can do to
improve the function of our immune
system in fact I feel like anytime the
winter months roll around we start to
see the same list of things surface
online and in the press and I don't want
to diminish these things they are in
fact the Bedrock of maintaining and
enhancing the function of your innate
immune system so what are those well
some of these will be pretty obvious
things like getting enough
quality sleep each night we know for
instance that if you're sleep deprived
so especially if you stay up all night
but certainly even if you only get 50%
or 75% of your sleep requirement that
your innate immune system is going to
suffer it's not going to be as effective
at combating flu or colds in addition to
that we know that exercise of specific
type and specific duration and specific
intensity can serve to bolster the
innate immune system and we'll talk
about the specific exercise protocols
that can best achieve that we also hear
and it's absolutely true that we need
adequate nutrition if we are in a
caloric deficit for instance if we're
trying to diet through the winter months
which many people try to do that can
place our innate immune system in a bit
of a compromised state that said things
like intermittent fasting or even longer
duration fast have been implicated and
here I really want to underscore
implicated in brief improvements in the
function of the immune system however
extended fast or not eating enough
calories to maintain body weight for
many many days in a row can actually
compromise the function of the innate
immune system I'll go into this a bit
deeper in a moment and then of course we
hear about stress that we're all
supposed to regulate our levels of
stress not get too stressed and here I
have to put an asterisk next to those
statements because yes indeed chronic
stress meaning stress that continues day
after day after day or even short
periods of stress that impede our
ability to sleep at night can indeed
reduce the functioning of our innate
immune system however it's also clear
that short bouts of stress provided that
they don't inhibit our ability to sleep
that night can actually enhance the
function of the immune system and this
is something that I don't think is
talked about enough you know we hear so
often that quote unquote cortisol is bad
it's a stress hormone listen cortisol is
fantastic provided that it is elevated
early in the day and not late in the day
or evening also cortisol does have
thresholds Beyond which if it's too high
can be bad for us but it's also the case
that if cortisol levels are too low
that's bad for us and it's especially
bad for the functioning of our immune
system because glucocorticoids of which
cortisol is have an important role in
activating those natural killer cells of
the innate immune system they are one of
the primary signals by which those inter
lucans like interlan 1 and interlan 6
are deployed in our body and so very
often we'll hear stress increases
inflammation and indeed interlukin 1
interlan 6 are pro-inflammatory you
might think oh my goodness I don't want
that I don't want cortisol I don't want
these Incans elevated but guess what the
inflammation response is also an
important component of that innate
immune system that allows us to combat
infections so in trying to keep our
innate immune system tuned up I realize
that's not a biological statement tuned
up but keep our immune system
functioning at its best we want
inflammation available as a tool to
combat infection we want cortisol
available as a way to activate that
inflammation and other aspects of our
immune system we just don't want so much
cortisol and so much inflammation that
we can't sleep and that our gut
microbiome suffers and that brings me to
the other component that's important for
the basic functioning of your immune
system so that you can be at your
strongest when you inevitably encounter
those cold and flu viruses why do I say
inevitably look if you exist in the
world that is if you live live on planet
Earth you are going to be bombarded with
different viruses and bacteria and
funguses and all this stuff throughout
your days and yes in those winter months
because people are spending more time
indoors and they're touching each other
and surfaces more breathing on each
other more sneezing on each other more
and so on and so forth there is more
propagation of colds and flu so if we
take a step back and we ask how can I
have my immune system as strong and
ready as possible to combat cold and flu
viruses we get to those Basics it's make
sure you're getting enough quality sleep
each night how much is enough however
much you need in order to not feel
sleepy during the day except maybe the
requirement for a short nap of anywhere
from 10 to 30 minutes not everyone
requires that but that's perfectly
normal to have an afternoon dip in
energy that can be restored with a short
nap or non-sleep deep bre we'll provide
links to non-sleep deep breast and other
tools in the show note captions that you
know are zero cost tools to allow you to
recover your energy some people just
simply take a nap and that sort of thing
if you want tools for improving your
sleep and making sure that you're
getting enough quality sleep each night
we will also provide a link to our zeroc
cost sleep tool kit that details that in
PDF form it just lists out the things
that you can do or take if that's your
choice and so on and so forth and of
course we've done episodes on quality
nutrition and what that means we've done
episodes on stress and how to combat
stress and we've done episodes on the
so-called gut microbiome but right now I
just want to mention that the gut
microbiome which are the trillions of
little microbacteria that interact
heavily with the immune system and help
support the immune system you want to
keep the gut microbiome healthy so
you'll notice that we include some tools
related to the gut microbiome here in a
moment and and this is very important
keep in mind that the microbiome doesn't
just exist in the gut so often these
days we hear about the gut microbiome
and I'm oh so happy that the gut
microbiome is getting the attention that
it deserves in the context of mental
health physical health and performance
but we can't forget that the microbiome
also exists on the surface of the eye
and in the nasal passages and indeed the
microbiome that's specific to the nasal
passages as I mentioned before is very
different from the microbiome that
exists within the mouth and the
microbiome that exists within the mucosa
of the nasal passages seems to be the
most effective at combating any viruses
that we encounter especially cold and
flu viruses so while ideally you would
never encounter a colder flu virus we
know that if the colder flu viruses go
in through the nasal passages you stand
the greatest chance of combating that
particular cold or flu so what does that
mean this is where I get to make a
strong push for being a nasal breather
certainly in sleep you want to be a
nasal breather but also throughout the
day unless you're speaking or unless
you're exercising hard enough that you
need to breathe through your mouth or
unless you're eating being a nasal
breather is known to provide the right
millu the right environment to keep that
nasal microbiome at its healthiest and
to promote the diversity of microbiota
in the nasal passages that can best
protect you against colds and flu and
there are a growing number of studies
that point to this fact I'll provide a
link to one that I like very much which
is entitled alterations in oral nasal
Fingal microbiota and salivary proteins
in mouth breathing children this is but
one study pointing to the fact that
being a nasal breather is a good thing
mouth breathing children and mouth
breathing adults meaning children and
adults that default to mouth breathing
tend to get more in C of of the upper
respiratory tract including colds and
flu consciously focusing on nasal
breathing is one of the best things that
we can all do to combat any colds or flu
that we might encounter so earlier we
talked about trying to avoid touching
your eyes at least without washing your
hands first or sanitizing your hands
first after you meet somebody keeping in
mind that most people do that
unconsciously here we are also saying
when you enter a room you're hanging out
with peoplebe you're waiting for public
transportation or you're at work work or
walking down the hallway unless you are
exercising hard unless you are talking
try to focus on being a nasal breather
there are a bunch of other reasons to be
a nasal breather as well but this is one
of the primary ones and I'll provide a
link to another reference which is the
book Jaws by my colleagues at Stanford
which talks about nasal breathing and
the importance of nasal breathing but
also the degree to which children and
adults open themselves up to increased
levels of viral infections as well as
bacterial infections but viral
infections in particular when they rely
on mouth breathing and the incredible
benefits of doing this very simple zeroc
cost thing of whenever you can
consciously remember to breathing
through your nose as opposed to
breathing through your mouth and just as
an additional point about nasal
breathing because I can't resist telling
you this I just think it's so cool such
an interesting
adaptation when we breathe through our
nose we heat the air in a way that's
very different from the way we heat the
air when we mouth breathe and by heating
the air that's coming into the nasal
passages it shifts the probability that
colder flu viruses will successfully
embed in the mucosal lining and infect
the underlying cells and get into the
other cells and tissues of our body so
this whole thing about nasal breathing
is important and effective at the level
of temperature regulation of the millu
within the nose and therefore the
viruses that end up in the nose as well
as the mucosal line and the chemicals
made by the mucosal line
and again the nose is a very different
place than the mouth in fact I'll
provide a link to yet another paper uh
which is entitled human nasal microbiota
it's a really interesting paper it's
actually an interview with a scientist
who's expert in the nasal microbiome
talking about how this structure within
our nose really is the primary defense
site by which we destroy potentially
incoming viruses so if it sounds overly
simple just breathe through your nose it
is very simple but it's also very
effective now it's also clearly the case
that keeping your gut microbiome is
advantageous for keeping your innate
immune system at its most robust level
of functioning and I should mention that
your gut microbiome isn't just about
your stomach you know we hear the word
gut and we think stomach but it's
actually the entire length of your
digestive tract from your mouth out the
other end and different microbiota exist
at different locations along that tract
of mucosa and there are a couple things
that one can do in order to make sure
that the gut microbiome is best
supported along that entire length the
first one is that and this was covered
on the episode that we did with my
colleague Justin sonenberg who is a
world expert in the gut microbiome and
that is to consume anywhere from two to
four servings of low sugar fermented
foods per day so things like sourkraut
things like kimchi things like kefir
things like kombucha it can be a little
bit of work to figure out which of these
you like and which ones you're willing
to consume on a regular basis but it's
very clear that the brine you know that
kind of uh salty solution around the
sauerkraut and by the way when I say
sauerkraut what we're talking about here
is the type that has to be refrigerated
it contains what are called live
cultures as opposed to the sauerkraut
that can exist in the non-refrigerated
portion of the store or pickles that
also have that Brine and that have to be
kept in the refrigerator even before
they're opened and of course like yogurt
which have active live cultures those
are the sorts of things that are going
to best support the diversity of
microbiota along the entire length of
the gut microbiome such that your gut
microbiome can do its job in supporting
your nervous system but here especially
in the context of today's discussion
your immune system now the low sugar
component of low sugar fermented foods
is important because what we know is
that if you're consuming yogurts with a
lot of sugar or you're consuming
kombucha with high levels of sugar or
you're consuming pickles or sauerkraut
that have a lot of sugar in them you're
probably going to start to create some
other issues related to the sugar what
you're really looking for are these low
sugar fermented foods and they can be a
little bit tricky to seek out in the
store but they're usually there and once
you identify the ones that you like you
should really aim to get two to four
servings of those per day you can also
consume a Prebiotic or probiotic in the
form of capsule form things like ag1
athletic greens also contain Prebiotic
probiotic but it's very clear that
consuming two to four servings of low
sugar fermented foods per day is among
the best ways to promote health of the
gut microbiome and that the gut
microbiome is so so important for
keeping the innate immune system
thriving such that it can combat the
colds or flu that are trying to bombard
your system now there's another tool
that you can use to enhance your gut
microbiome I have to warn you this one
might make a few of you um cringe a
little bit but this is one that I
actually started doing about four months
ago um it's an interesting one it kind
of dates back to some older quote
unquote traditional medicine practices
but it makes really good logical sense
to be fair I'm not aware of any
randomized control trial exploring the
use of this protocol but it's so simple
and completely cost-free and it stands
so strongly on the logic of how the gut
and oral microbiome work that frankly I
started doing it and you know whether or
not it's placebo effect or not I don't
know but I feel better and it's so easy
to do and it stands to potentially
improve the fun of your gut microbiome
enough that I figured I would at least
share it with you and then you can
decide so what this protocol essentially
consists of is before you go to sleep at
night or in the morning you pour
yourself a little bit of water whatever
water you happen to consume just clean
clear water and then you take a sip of
that water when you wake up in the
morning and you swish it around in your
mouth and then you swallow it now for
those of you that are like oh gross
let's think about this is it really
gross to swish a little bit of water
around in your mouth and then swallow
that water when you first wake up prior
to brushing your teeth of course well it
might seem gross to you but throughout
the night when you're sleeping
especially if you are a nasal breather
while you sleep the environment within
your mouth is such that you're breeding
a lot of bacteria you are creating all
those little
microbacteria that potentially can
inhabit your digestive tract and provide
at least some of the substrate for the
microbiota in your digestive tract to
thrive and if that seems gross to you
keep in mind that's what having a
healthy gut microbiome really is all
about so the protocol is very simple at
zero cost you take a swig of water swish
it around and swallow it oddly it
doesn't taste bad um in fact it'll just
taste like swallowing um and in fact it
tastes like swallowing a little bit of
water it's not as if it tastes like um
bad breath or something like that it's a
very simple protocol that again no
randomized control trials but really
stands on the logic of how the oral
microbiome and the gut microbiome
interact and because what we're talking
about here is supporting the function of
your gut microbiome such that it
supports the function of your inate
immune system such that you can avoid
colds and flu at least to me it seems
like a pretty low bar yes okay so to
bolster your inade immune system you
want to get that quality sleep as often
as you possibly can you want to support
the gut microbiome in the ways that we
just described what about exercise we
hear it all the time time exercise is so
good for us it enhances the immune
system and on and on and listen I'm a
huge believer in exercise I personally
like to do three bouts of cardiovascular
exercise per week one long one medium
one short and I do three bouts of
resistance training each week all of
that and specifically what I do is
available to you as a zeroc cross
protocol in the form of a PDF we have a
link to that in the show note captions I
also have a whole episode about
foundational Fitness and so on and so on
the discussion we're going to have now
now is about what general forms of
exercise actually do support the innate
immune system and and this is really
important what forms of exercise
actually deplete your innate immune
system this isn't talked about enough I
think there are certain intensities and
durations of exercise that make us more
vulnerable to colds and flu so we're
going to discuss that before we do that
I want to just briefly touch into
something that I hear a lot which is the
question if I'm feeling a little bit
rundown should I exercise or not and to
be honest there isn't a straightforward
answer to that question it's impossible
for me or for you to know whether or not
you were indeed exposed to a cold or flu
and you're starting to combat it at the
level of your Nate immune system or
whether or not you're just you know
feeling a little bit
sluggish however what we do know is that
if you are feeling malaise at the level
of the body like your body is feeling
different it's feeling heavier you're
feeling tired you're feeling tired at a
time of day that doesn't make sense
given your usual patterns of being tired
you're feeling tired in a way that
doesn't make sense given how much sleep
you got the night before right I mean
here what we're talking about is ruling
out any possible you know life stressor
you were up too late or you drank
caffeine at the wrong time or something
like that what we know is that you're if
you're feeling that General malaise
across your whole body it is fairly
likely that you're coming down with
something and that your best response to
that would be to go home take a hot
shower or bath I'll explain why you
would want to do that in a few minutes
and then get into bed early and even if
you can't fall asleep to just be as
still and as relaxed as possible we know
that if you push into bouts of intense
activity or even just push yourself to
engage in activity when you're feeling
run down at that sort of whole body
level maybe a little tickle in your
throat you are going to compromise the
function of your innate immune system
and it's very likely that you're going
to get more sick than you would
otherwise so here's my suggestion if
you're starting to feel rundown at the
level of whole body malaise or you just
don't feel right
you're best off taking a hot shower bath
and getting into bed or just getting
into bed and trying to rest and get as
much sleep probably even a little bit of
extra sleep and here's why that whole
body malaise that extra fatigue that's
not easily explained by other factors in
your
life have to do with the fact that when
your innate immune system is activated
meaning it's already combating a cold or
flu interlukin 1 and interlukin 6 have a
way of interacting with a particular
brain area called the dorsal rafay
nucleus which is choa block full of
neurons that release serotonin and
serotonin from the dorsal rafay nucleus
acts on specific regions of your
hypothalamus areas like the preoptic
region for those of you that want to
know and other areas of the hypothalamus
that generate a state of sleepiness in
addition when we are getting sick our
sleep patterns change we feel like we
need to sleep more but we don't feel as
rested from that sleep and that has to
do with the ways that serotonin
interacts with some of the components of
the brain circuitry involved in sleep
that controls slow wave or deep sleep
and this is a whole discussion unto
itself I actually covered a lot of the
mechanistic aspects of this business of
immune induced sleepiness and Malay is
associated with feeling sick in an
episode about interactions between the
neural and immune system that I will
also provide a link to in the show note
captions but suffice to say if you're
feeling that whole body Mala is and
especially if you also have a little bit
of a throat tickle you're just not
feeling right for you you're not
accustomed to feeling that way at that
time of day or night well then I
encourage you to get rest because
chances are you're already combating an
infection however if you are out and
about a lot during the winter months or
you're interacting with a lot of people
by virtue of work or public
transportation or whatever the gym Etc
you're a school teacher maybe your kids
are coming home with colds and flu and
you're not yet feeling that malaise
you're not feeling any throat tickle
you're not getting that kind of um kind
of burning or tickle within your nasal
passages when you breathe you know we're
all familiar with these things the
watering the eyes that kind of precedes
the getting the full-blown cold or flu
well if you're not experiencing that
stuff and you want to keep your inate
immune system strong and able to combat
off colds and flu then we know that
exercise can be an excellent way to
increase the output of that innate
immune system what I mean by that is the
appropriate intensity and duration of
exercise can act as a stressor that
promotes a bit of inflammation yes the
release of cyto kindes and a bit of
activation of the innate immune system
including the production of more white
blood cells natural killer cells such
that you're sort of prompting the innate
immune system to almost think that
there's something to battle such that if
you ever encounter an infection you can
defeat it right off the bat so we're
going to get granular here about what we
mean by proper intensity and duration of
exercise there's a wonderful review that
was published in 2019 in the Journal of
Sport and Health Science entitled The
compelling link between physical
activity and the body's defense system
and there's a lot to this review article
but I'll just highlight a few of the
critical features that are going to
directly relate to protocols that I
think all of you are going to be
interested in first of all we know that
exercise that's of 60 Minutes in
duration or less and that is intense but
not allout effort okay here we're not
talking about percentage of single
repetition max weight here we're not
talking about 70 to 85% of one's VO2 max
what we're talking about is you
subjectively gauging what is a 10 out of
10 effort like you could not do any more
you could not contribute any more effort
to that exercise bout and that's true
whether or not we're talking about
resistance training exercise or
cardiovascular exercise like running or
rowing or things of that sort what we
know is that if you do that sort of
exercise for about 60 Minutes or
Less you promote the exchange of
components between the blood and the
lymphatic system that increase the
circulation of those cells and chemicals
within the innate immune system such
that not just during exercise but for
many many hours afterwards maybe even as
much as 24 hours afterwards your innate
immune system level of Baseline activity
is ramped up allowing you to better
combat infections such as colds and flu
okay so this is an incentive for getting
a regular exercise of 60 Minutes or Less
per
day making it of sufficient intensity
for your anate immune system to deploy
more of those chemicals and for your
lymphatic and blood circulation to
increase their exchange of materials
enough that your Nate immune system is
bolstered however it is absolutely not
the case that more is better in fact
it's probably the case that less is
better here's what we know for sure and
this review covers sort of the extreme
of these examples but for instance
people that do bouts of walking each day
for about 60 Minutes brisk walking
experience
increased te- cell function so that's an
immune cell that goes out and combats
cold and flu viruses and natural killer
cell activity so those increase increase
macras function you are now familiar
with these cells if you don't know
exactly what they do just keep in mind
that you heard about these in the
context of what the innate immune system
does to go out and fight colds and
flu cyto coses increase but not
dramatically okay so this is a mild
inflammation response stress hormones
such as cortisol epinephrine norep
nephrine also called adrenaline and
noradrenaline those are deployed as well
so 60 minutes or less of this moderate
to high-intensity exercise creates this
mild stress response and an increase in
the function of the inate immune system
however people that run a marathon and
as I recall a marathon is 26.2 miles if
I'm not
mistaken they experience a very
different pattern of immune response to
that long bout of exercise so here we're
comparing one hour of exercise to 3
hours is that what it takes to run a
marathon I have some friends that are
marathoners I'm guessing about three
maybe four hours if you're really slow
but somewhere between you know I don't
know two and a half and three hours if
you're trained up and you're doing it
and you're doing them regularly well
here's the point people who just ran a
marathon and people who have been
training for a marathon and are
approaching that Marathon are severely
immune compromised the levels of their
te- cell function are way below Baseline
meaning their inate immune system is not
functioning nearly as well as it would
if they were to not exercise at all
their natural killer cell activity is
also greatly diminished these are huge
huge reductions in these cells that is
in the function of the inate immune
system and their stress hormones and
their inflammatory molecules such as
cyto circulating in their blood are
extremely high now again we're
representing opposite ends of the
spectrum here with 1 hour or less of
exercise daily versus 26.2 mile marathon
exercise or half marathons as the case
may be and let me be very direct I'm not
discouraging people from running or
training for marathons or half marathons
I think that's great just understand
what you're doing to your immune system
when you do that and take the necessary
precautions but I think most people
listening to this are trying to think
about ways that they can avoid getting
colds and flu and certainly running
marathons is not going to be the way to
do that quite the contrary the way to do
that is in addition to the other things
we've been talking about to get regular
exercise maybe not every single day I'm
actually aan of taking one day per week
completely off from exercise usually on
that day I'll do some sauna and cold if
I have it available to me but the point
is this you don't have to exercise for
an hour a day in order to get this
Improvement in the inate immune response
data show that you can get this
Improvement in anate immune response
with as little as 20 minutes per day and
probably even as little as 12 minutes
per day however if you're going to try
and accomplish this increase in the
innate immune system function or output
with a shorter bout of exercise such as
12 minutes it better be 12 minutes of
very high-intensity training in fact
that's what lands on my uh for me it's
Friday but it doesn't really matter
which day of the week there is one day
of the week where I do a very short bout
of cardiovascular exercise but I'm
sprinting hard for anywhere from 20
seconds to a minute and then I'm taking
a brief period of rest and then
repeating that for a total of 12 minutes
now some people here oh only 12 minutes
of exercise required and they default to
12 minutes every single time they train
I don't think that's a good idea I think
we can take the law of averages here and
say the following I do believe everyone
should do a combination of
cardiovascular training and resistance
training perhaps I think in general not
on the same days but if you're going to
do that and you want to maintain healthy
immune system function my suggestion
what I do is unless it's the long bout
of cardiovascular training that I do
once a week and long for me means 60 to
90 minutes and sometimes longer if it's
a hike which certainly doesn't require
that much intensity
I suggest warming up for about 5 to 10
minutes and then limiting your total
workout duration to about 50 minutes
maybe 60 minutes if that's what's
required to complete what you need to do
in order to keep with your exercise
goals but to be very careful about
exceeding 75 minutes of exercise in any
one single exercise bout and if you
remember back to the beginning of the
episode when I said that I track what I
do on a day-to-day basis and I don't do
it in a very detailed way but I do take
note of when I've gotten a bad flu or
cold I can tell you that in almost every
single case where I've gotten a bad flu
or cold there are two things that have
preceded that bad flu or cold one is
sleep deprivation typically it would be
nights where I got two hours of sleep or
less for more than one night okay the
second thing is anytime that I really
pushed it with exercise and went all out
and I went for 75 minutes and then I
continued to 90 minutes and then maybe
later that day because somebody invited
me on a run or something like that I
also did that second run or that second
workout of some kind could be running in
the morning and weight training in the
afternoon some people can do that kind
of training on a regular basis even and
not get sick I am not such a person I've
managed to maintain fairly consistent
Fitness output meaning the three
cardiovascular and the three weight
training sessions per week for more than
several decades now and part of the
reason I think I've been able to do that
is because I don't ever push too hard
for too long within a given workout so
this is really a call for moderation in
terms of the duration and intensity of
the exercise that you're doing but we're
not talking about really being laidback
we're not talking about easy workouts
what we're talking about is an hour or
less of moderate intensity to
high-intensity exercise depending on the
duration of that exercise and keeping in
mind that when you're doing that you are
activating that innate immune system you
are literally creating an immune
response you're increasing inflammation
you're increasing those cyto kindes
you're increasing stress stress hormones
we have to start to think about exercise
for what it is which is a form of stress
that induces adaptations Dr Andy Galpin
talked a lot about this in the series
that he did on exercise physiology it's
an excellent series that covers
everything from strength to hypertrophy
to speed to endurance nutrition
supplementation you can find all that at
hubman lab.com very
easily exercise is a very potent tool we
know that we know that in the context of
changing Aesthetics like body mass
composition you know increasing muscle
reducing fat we know that in the context
of reducing resting heart rate reducing
resting blood pressure we know that in
the context of all these other health
metrics here we're talking about using
exercise as a very potent tool to
increase the function of the Nate immune
system to keep you healthy not just
through the winter months but around the
year and especially if you're getting
less sleep if you're interacting with
kids or adults that are carrying
infections home from school or work on a
regular basis or maybe you even work in
an environment like a hospital or a
clinic where you're regularly
interacting with patients that have
these issues one thing that I often get
asked is if I am sleep deprived should I
exercise and that's a little bit of a
tricky one my initial response for many
years was no no if you're sleep deprived
you're better off not
exercising however I now need to qualify
that answer because there are data
showing that if you're sleep deprived
and you exercise especially if you
exercise early in the day and it doesn't
disrupt your sleep schedule so it's not
making you go to sleep even later the
next night that it actually can cause
some adjustments in the function of your
immune system and in the way that you
regulate your blood sugar that offset
some of the negative effects of sleep
deprivation that said you should never
ever compromise the amount of sleep you
could get in order to get exercise such
that you run yourself down so what I'm
really saying here is if you get one bad
night's sleep should you skip your
workout and you feel like ah you know
I'm not feeling sick and should I work
out or should I go back to sleep
probably going back to sleep is the
better idea but if you don't have the
option to go back to sleep for whatever
reason you can't fall back asleep then
you would be wise to do a bout of
exercise but I would suggest reducing
the intensity and duration of that
exercise by about 25% maybe even 50% and
that should allow you to offset any of
the negative effects of sleep
deprivation for that one night keep in
mind exercise is not a replacement for
sleep and then to allow you to get to
sleep at the appropriate time later that
night and back onto a regular schedule
keeping your innate immune system tuned
up and ready to combat any colds or flu
now one more point about exercise and
here we're also going to dovetail in an
important point about nutrition in the
review that I mentioned a few moments
ago they cover some of the data from
studies exploring the post exercise
stress response so this is the post
exercise induced increase in things like
cortisol those natural killer cells the
production of white blood cells and so
on it's very clear that if you are in a
state of chronic stress because you're
you're exercising a lot Andor because
you're not sleeping enough or for
whatever reason maybe you have a lot of
Life stress it's very clear that
ingesting
carbohydrates after exercise can help
attenuate some of the inflammation that
exercise
induces when we talk about carbohydrates
we're talking about rice oatmeal pasta
those sorts of things soal complex
carbohydrates and fruit post exercise
has been shown to attenuate to reduce
some of the markers of inflammation by
about 30 to
40% when contrasted with water only
intake especially if you're training
fasted so for those of you like me that
like to wake up in the morning and just
drink fluids you know for me it's water
y bate coffee and by the way I've said
before that people should delay their
caffeine intake 90 minutes if and only
if they're experiencing an afternoon
crash but that if you are exercising
first thing in the morning it's
perfectly fine to ingest your caffeine
right away so that gives you increase in
energy for that exercise that's
certainly what I do on days that I
exercise but if you fast and then you're
drinking caffeine and then you're
exercising and that exercise goes longer
than 60 Minutes certainly if it goes
longer than 75 minutes you would do well
to ingest some complex carbohydrates
maybe also some fruit perhaps not
immediately after exercise but within
the 45 minutes or so or hour or so after
exercise so that you're not ramping up
those inflammatory molecules and leaving
them ramped up for many hours into the
morning and throughout the day because
of course this episode is not about
exercise and nutrition but here we're
talking about the role that exercise and
nutrition play in helping us combat
colds and flu by increasing the function
of that innate immune system and the
reasons why carbohydrates can have this
effect on cortisol Etc is an interesting
and important discussion into itself
we'll leave it for another episode but
keep that in mind also I don't know
about you but a nice bowl of oatmeal
some fruit and a protein drink or some
eggs after an hour or so of exercise in
the morning when I haven't eaten
anything since the night before tastes
really really good so continuing with
the theme of things that we can do at
the level of behaviors to improve the
function of our innate immune system and
combat colds and flu perhaps even
prevent us from getting colds and flu at
all but certainly help combat them if
they've initially made their way into
our system but we haven't developed
full-blown symptoms and we want to
prevent those full-blown symptoms is the
use of deliberate heat exposure in
particular sauna there's a nice study on
this that was published very recently
2023 the title of the study is the
effects of a single and series of
finished sauna sessions on the immune
system response and heat shock protein
70 levels in trained and untrained men
it's a very interesting study they
compared athletically trained and
non-athletic trained men as most of you
probably know when you get into a hot
sauna heart rate increases there's vasod
dilation there's the increase in the
release of heat shock proteins there's
the increase in things like dorphin
which if it's sufficiently hot are
increased to levels that make us feel
kind kind of agitated and not so good we
have to actively calm ourselves in the
sauna so we're not talking about an easy
cruise at 150° fenhe we're talking about
getting up into the you know 180 degree
Fahrenheit or 210 degree Fahrenheit
range maybe even higher if you're heat
adapted and that the dorphin makes you
feel lousy in the short term but that it
upregulates a bunch of different
biological mechanisms that give you kind
of low-level Euphoria and actually the
capacity to experience more feelings of
well-being from the endorphins that you
make after you get out of the sauna this
is oh so important to understand whether
or not we're talking about exercise or
deliberate cold exposure or deliberate
heat exposure what happens during the
heat exposure cold exposure exercise is
more often than not just the trigger for
the long-term adaptation that we're
seeking just like exercise increases
your heart rate and blood pressure but
then leads to reductions in resting
heart rate and blood pressure and so on
and so forth this study is interesting
and there are a lot of different
takeaways from this study because they
compare these two different
populations I'll just give you the top
Contour of what the protocol entailed
there were 10 sauna sessions each of
those sauna sessions were three rounds
of 15 minutes of sauna so one session
meant going into the sauna the sauna was
of a given temperature but I think for
most people what's going to work in
terms of what parallels the study is
going to be somewhere between 176 and
210 degrees Fahrenheit depending on how
heat adapted you are always be safe
don't do this if you're pregnant don't
this if you're a child Etc so they're
doing three rounds of 15 minutes each
separated by 2 minutes during that 2
minutes they take a cool shower where
they cool off in some way they're not
going into a cold plunge but they're
cooling off with a cool
shower and they're doing that three
times that's one
session they do 10 sessions those sauna
sessions were spaced apart by at least a
few days and the entire experiment
meaning all 10 sessions were completed
within a 3-we period and then a bunch of
things were measured like the amount of
white blood cells and immune cells that
were deployed after the first session
versus the third versus the eth versus
the 10th and so on as well as the levels
of cortisol and inflammatory markers
there are a lot of different things
measured in this study here's what we
know sauna baths as they're calling them
resulted in a statistically significant
increase in cortisol concentration after
the first and the 10th sauna session
okay so every time you go into the sauna
you're getting an increase in cortisol
we know that because the heat is a
stressor again don't think about heat as
oh you're just kind of relaxing in the
onet so nice you're getting a cortisol
response cortisol is a glucocorticoid
stress hormone as it's sometimes called
which can be a good thing if it sets in
motion a number of other things such as
the increase in the activity of the
anate immune system and indeed that is
what they observed after and here I'm
paraphrasing after the first and 10th
Saab baths they witnessed an increase in
lucite count lucaites are a particular
type of cell of the inate immune system
however only after the last sauna
session did this change reach
statistical significance in the trained
group so what they observed was that
athletes who are trained are used to
being in high heat conditions because of
their athletic training people who are
not trained in athletics are not used to
that there are a lot of different ways
to look at these data but the simplest
takeaway is that if you are already very
heat adapted because you do sauna
regularly or you exercise regularly well
then it's going to take a stronger
stimulus or more sauna either longer or
hotter or more frequent to get the sorts
of increases in innate immune response
as compared to someone who's never done
sauna who's not exercising regularly and
that just makes sense if something isn't
stressful to you you're not going to get
the stimulation of that innate immune
response and the overall takeaway from
this study was that I do believe that if
you're feeling run down a little bit bit
or if you're just trying to keep colds
and flu at Bay having some regular is
practice of getting into the sauna for
three rounds of 15 minutes separated by
two-minute cool off you don't
necessarily have to do a cold shower or
a cold Plunge in between although I
don't see why you couldn't or wouldn't
you could also just get out of the sauna
and be in the cool air and then get back
in or perhaps you do something more akin
to what's been shown in other studies
that explore the relationship between
heat exposure and immune response which
is to do two rounds of 20 minutes or one
round of 30 minutes in the sauna
whatever you can do safely and
comfortably keep in mind safety is Key
Don't harm yourself I say that not to
protect me but to protect
you that sauna is an effective way of
increasing the activity of the inate
immune system it increases Lucy levels
yes it increases cortisol levels but in
a way that promote the activity of the
inate immune system however and here we
are back to exactly the same thing we
said about exercise if you're already
feeling really rund down feeling kind of
heaviness in the body you don't feel
well you're starting to get some
sniffles don't get in a very hot sauna
but for sake of keeping colds and flu at
Bay sure do three rounds of 15 minutes
in the sauna between 176 degrees 210
degrees whatever you can safely tolerate
take those two-minute breaks in between
maybe do a cold shower or coolish shower
maybe just stand outside the sauna in
between if you're feeling really strong
do a coal plunge for a minut two minutes
in between you don't have to but you
certainly could and then get back in and
then repeat or just do one 20 minute
session or 30 minute session all of
which have been shown to promote the
activity of the Nate immune system
however and I realize I said this before
but I feel like I need to say it again
especially For You hardcore exercisers
or people that really feel like oh I can
push through if you're already sick and
you have the symptoms of a colder flu
you want to limit the amount of stress
to your body you want to get into bed
and sleep if you can't sleep you want to
relax you do not want to exercise you
should not exercise not only do you
stand to get other people ill by going
places where you exercise but even if
you exercise at home or in total
isolation you're going to prolong the
duration of that illness because there
are many many reasons why being still
slowing your circulation and allowing
your innate and then in that case your
adaptive immune system to kick in and
combat those infections is going to get
you back into a regular exercise and
work regimen much much faster than would
be the case if you were to push through
okay so now we get to the portion of the
discussion that I think probably many
people are anticipating which is what
can you take to reduce the probability
of getting a colder flu or shorten the
duration of a colder flu and I actually
put out a call on social media I asked
the question on Instagram and on X
formerly called Twitter you know what do
you do for a colder flu and what are you
curious about in terms of what one can
take for cold or flu and I got thousands
upon thousands of answers
however many of those answers converged
on some common things things like taking
garlic I heard for instance that some
people are chewing a raw clove of garlic
every day during the winter um I heard
about people who take fermented garlic
some people swear by eonia some people
swear by eonia vitamin C and Zinc now
there are far too many compounds that
exist in the wellness and indeed in the
medical literature to cover all of them
so I'm going to highlight a few that I
think are especially interesting and
that have been shown in p reviewed
science to be potentially useful some of
these you've heard of before and some of
them I think are going to be surprising
or at least new to you first let's
consider what most people believe to be
a very effective way to hasten colds or
flu that is to make them last shorter
duration of time than they would
otherwise maybe even prevent colds or
flu the big one there is vitamin C we
hear all the time vitamin C antioxidant
I grew up in an area where the Noel
prize winning chemist lonus Pauling who
was a fanatic about vitamin C he took
many many grams of vitamin C each day
used to tout the benefits of vitamin
C here's the deal there is some evidence
and it's not great frankly that points
to the fact that taking 6 to8 grams
grams so that's 6,000 to 8,000
milligrams of Vitamin C per day that is
a lot of vitamin
C each day can
perhaps delay the onset of a cold or
shorten the duration of a cold so here
we're talking about very high doses and
not a very robust effect I should
mention that for most people who aren't
accustomed to taking much vitamin C if
you were to take 6 to eight grams of
vitamin C in capsule or powder or pill
form chances are you're going to
experience some significant gastric
distress some people can build up to
that level or take it with food in a way
that doesn't cause that gastric distress
but many people will experience gastric
distress there's been a lot said about
vitamin C and its other potential roles
in our physiology and I don't want to
touch on those now because it may have
some interesting roles in other aspects
of our physiology but I have to say that
in scouring the literature on vitamin C
I encountered a recent paper so this was
published in 2023 and the title of this
paper is retraction extra dose of
vitamin C based on a daily
supplementation shorten the common cold
a metaanalysis of nine randomized
controlled
trials what is this paper that was
recently published why is retraction the
first word in the title Well turns out
that the metaanalysis of nine randomized
control trials showing a small but
significant Improvement in the outcomes
for colds and flu or reduction in
probability of getting colds and flu
that study was retracted and it was
retracted on the basis of multiple
instances of an error in which the
placebo groups had been double counted
in Trials more than the two intervention
arms so there were some serious data
analysis flaws in that metaanalysis now
that is not to say that vitamin C is of
zero benefit for reducing the
probability of colds and flu but must
say provided that you're getting
sufficient amounts of vitamin C from
your food intake maybe you're also get a
little bit in your vitamin mineral
supplement or if you take a foundational
supplement like ag1 or something similar
almost certainly you're getting enough
vitamin C it does not seem that taking
high doses of vitamin C and I would
Place 6 to8 grams of vitamin C in the
high dose range is going to be effective
for treating or preventing colds and flu
so more data may arrive in the near
future but vitamin C is probably not a
very good investment if you're taking it
solely for the purpose of enhancing your
immune system function and staving off
colds and flu now what about vitamin D
we hear a lot these days about the
importance of having sufficient vitamin
D levels and ideally everyone would get
their vitamin D levels measured by
regular blood test I do get my blood
work done every 6 months I find it be
incredibly informative tells me what's
going on below the hood in ways that I
never could be aware of where I not to
get that test but I realize that there's
a cost to those tests and not everyone
can afford
them I think most Physicians would agree
that supplementing with anywhere from a
th000 to 2,000 IU of vitamin D per day
is probably safe for most people and
will buffer that level of vitamin D in
their system such that they're unlikely
to be deficient and unlikely to far
exceed what's safe in the
body however there are people who need
higher levels of vitamin D
supplementation in order to achieve
sufficient amounts of vitamin D for
their mental health and physical health
I mean vitamin D is involved in a lot of
different processes in the brain and
body now it is clear that people who are
vitamin D deficient so these are people
whose vitamin D level levels have been
measured oftentimes have diminished
immune system function and are more
prone to acute respiratory tract
infections there's a very lengthy and
very interesting review entitled vitamin
D supplementation to prevent acute
respiratory tract infections systematic
review and metaanalysis of individual
participant data this is a beast of a
thing um I did read it all very very
interesting many many
studies the exact takeaways from a large
review like this of 20 randomized
control trials is a little bit tricky I
mean they did conclude that vitamin D
supplementation did reduce the risk of
acute respiratory tract infection among
all the participants however the degree
of prevention was small to moderate in
some cases they did point out however
that just because people with low levels
of vitamin D tend to get colds and flu
more often than people that don't does
not necessarily mean that vitamin D
deficiencies are the reason for that for
instance we know that people that get
regular sunlight exposure and as
everyone knows I'm a big big proponent
of getting sunlight in your eyes as
early as possible in the day after
waking up and if it's cloudy out to get
even more time outside if you can and if
you can't get access to sunlight for
whatever reason to perhaps invest in a
10,000 Lux light tablet you can find
these online at reasonable cost you know
$100 to $200 in some
cases getting sunlight sets in motion a
huge number of different things
including increasing the amount of
vitamin D in your system but a bunch of
other things as well increases in
cortisol increases in dopamine increases
in serotonin that Cascade toward and
relate to improved immune system
function so what is the takeaway here I
think that for most people supplementing
with a th to 2,000 international units
of vitamin D it's probably safe however
if you need more vitamin D you won't
know that unless you take a vitamin D
test that is you measure the amount of
vitamin D in your bloodstream and some
people indeed need 5,000 to 10,000 IU of
vitamin D per day but you don't want to
overdose yourself on vitamin D that is
if you already have sufficiently high
levels of vitamin D in your system and
you're getting sufficient sunlight well
then taking 10,000 or more international
units of vitamin D could possibly be
detrimental I think it's fair to say
based on the metaanalysis and review
that I mentioned a moment ago and the
other papers that I was able to glean
that vitamin D itself is unlikely to be
the sole protectant against colds and
flu but it's probably a good thing to
include in your general kit of nutrition
and supplementation tools if your goal
is to keep your innate immune system
fighting off colds and flu sufficiently
other things that perhaps support the
innate immune system are going to be as
I mentioned earlier the things that
support the gut microbiome so those low
sugar fermented foods maybe a Prebiotic
probiotic capsule maybe something like
athletic greens ag1 although certainly
you could achieve sufficient microbiome
support from Foods if you're careful and
intentional about the foods that you
select now the other compound or
substance that we often hear about in
the context of colds or flu is eonia
eonia is a compound that has been
proposed to improve immune system
function now when you go into the data
and you explore what does taking eonia
tinctures or other forms of eonia really
do to avoid colds and flu the answer
that comes back is not much if anything
now is taking eonia dangerous probably
not however it has been shown in a few
studies that people that take eonia
regularly at high
doses can potentially impede the
function of their innate immune system
that is reductions in white blood cell
count reductions in those natural killer
cells so my suggestion would be if you
absolutely love e eona for whatever
reason you're convinced that it helps
you that you reserve to taking it when
you're starting to feel a little bit
rund down or perhaps just in the winter
month not months plural but month when
you're most prone to those cold and flu
infections but then not taking it
continuously throughout the year and
certainly not for more than four weeks
at a time but again if you're doing that
just know that there aren't really any
strong scientific data to support the
use of eona by contrast there are pretty
darn good data that support
supplementing with zinc as a way to
combat colds and flu in particular
colds now here the dosages really matter
it's been shown that if you take less
than 75 milligrams of zinc in supplement
form to try and impact the probability
of getting or shortening a common cold
it's not going to work you need to take
100 milligrams or more and now 100
milligrams or more of zinc for some
people it's going to cause some gastric
distress if you take it on an empty
stomach I've actually made the mistake
of taking I think it was 50 milligrams
of zinc on an empty stomach and I felt
really nauseous did not feel well so
don't take zinc on an empty stomach and
if you're trying to shorten a colder flu
that you think you've already contracted
or you're trying to keep a cold or flu
at Bay because you were around people
with cold or flu or you're just worried
about it taking 100 milligrams of zinc
perhaps divide it up into two doses of
50 milligrams each or maybe 100
milligrams all at once but making sure
that you take that with at least a
moderately sized or full meal certainly
could be advantageous keep in mind that
people that are older than 65 are
perhaps the ones that need to supplement
zinc the most also keep in mind that
children meaning people younger than 15
should probably not supplement with too
much zinc it can be problematic and
certainly pregnant women should have
talked to their doctor before
supplementing with zinc indeed anytime
you're going to take anything whether or
not you're young old pregnant or not you
should consult your physician before you
take anything or remove anything from
your health protocols one of the more
interesting aspects of supplementing
with zinc that I was able to find in the
literature is a three times faster
recovery rate for people that already
contracted a cold so in this study
people weren't taking 100 milligram but
the dosage came pretty close they were
taking 90 milligram per day of zinc
acetate and they experienced a three
times faster recovery rate from that
cold compared to people who were not
taking the zinc now of course there
could be other factors as well but the
study was fairly convincing so given
that zinc is fairly low cost given that
it's generally safe for most
people and the fact that if you take it
with food it doesn't cause any
discomfort supplementing with Inc at a
level of anywhere from 90 to 100
milligrams per day probably no more than
120 per day seems like a logical way to
Stave off colds and flu and reduce the
duration of a cold or flu should you
contract one now I want to be very clear
that I've been talking about colds and
flu kind of in uh in concert kind of
treating them more or less as the same
thing some of that is for sake of time
and simplicity most all the studies
showing a benefit of zinc are studies
showing the benefit of zinc for the
treatment or the hastening of colds not
for flu specifically however I consulted
with a few Physicians one of whom is
expert in this area and he said I didn't
see any reason why you wouldn't take
zinc if you had a flu there's no reason
to think that it would introduce any
kind of increased risk but again consult
with your physician before taking or
removing anything from your supplement
regimen now a lot of the compounds that
we're discussing are sort of
conventional in the sense that I think
most people have probably heard of them
already perhaps the most esoteric
sounding one thus far is eona which we
established probably not very helpful
for colds or flu but we've been talking
about vitamin C we've been talking about
zinc vitamin D making sure you're
getting your sunlight supporting your
microbiome and so on and so on one
compound that I'm guessing most people
perhaps have not heard of but that is
very interesting that in fact I've taken
before and that I stock in my supplement
cabinet in case I feel like I'm coming
down with something is an acetylcysteine
or Knack what is Knack Knack is a
precursor to glutathione what is
glutathione glutathione is the master
antioxidant it's involved in reducing
what are called reactive oxygen species
which build up in cells that are very
metabolically active reactive oxygen
species build up even more in cells that
are under stress or a body that's under
stress and it also has the property of
reducing reactive nitrogen species
reactive oxygen and reactive nitrogen
species significantly increase under
conditions of infection and having
sufficient levels of glutathione is a
good thing now netal is used in certain
clinics overseas and in the US as a way
to treat cystic fibrosis because it's
also a mucolytic and cystic fibrosis is
the buildup of fluid in the lungs and a
mucolytic substance is something that
loosens up the mucus and allows it to
flow more readily out of different
cavities of the body including the lungs
the nasal passages and sinuses and
indeed last winter I did unfortunately
get a cold I told you about once every
18 to 24 months I get a cold and it was
a pretty nasty 1 I was feeling super
congested at first I thought it was an
ear infection pretty quickly I realized
I had a cold and I was feeling so
congested I wasn't sleeping well and it
was suggested to me to take an
acetylcysteine I ended up doing that at
a dosage of anywhere from 600 to 900
milligrams three times per day so it was
a 600 to 900 milligram capsule depending
on which brand I purchased a lot of
different versions of this out there on
the market I took it morning late
morning and afternoon and indeed it is a
powerful mucolytic the mucus just starts
flowing out of you you better have an
extra box of tissues handy and that
greatly relieved the pressure in my
sinuses and the reason I liked using
Knack is because I've actively avoided
using decongestants that one can
purchase over the counter most
decongestants are of the Alpha One
Agonist variety what's an alpha 1
Agonist it causes Vaso constriction that
Vaso constriction can be beneficial in
preventing some of the intense
congestion that one gets when you have a
sinus infection or a cold or a flu but
then when those decongestants wear off
off one tends to get a rebound increase
in congestion and it's really painful
headache Etc in addition some
over-the-counter decongestants can be
habit forming not necessarily addictive
but habit forming and they don't seem to
have any other positive health benefits
so I prefer not to take decongestant if
I can avoid it I had a very good
experience with Knack and the use of
knack and acetal cysteine as a
decongestant and also as a way to
prevent getting colds and flu is not an
entirely new idea in fact there's a
paper dating back to 1997 entitled
attenuation of influenza-like
symptomology and Improvement of
cellmediated immunity with long-term
anical cinee treatment now in this study
they looked at people who were taking
600 milligrams of anal cysteine twice
per day for 6 months and what they
observed is that the people who took
anical cysteine had a significantly
lower probability of Contracting
influenza now this is but one study
there have been a few other studies and
unfortunately there isn't a large body
of research looking at Knack as a
preventive for colds and flu but the
data in this paper are interesting
enough and I was compelled by them
enough to seek out a physician who I
noce it was answering my prompts on
social media about what do you use for
colds and flu and when I put that out
there as I mentioned I got thousands of
responses on both Twitter X and on
Instagram and one particular physician
who happens to have a YouTube account
his name is Dr schwell he's a medical
doctor he works in an INT Ive care unit
and he deals with a lot of patients who
have different strains of flu in fact he
was the one that cued me to the fact
that this year there seems to be a fair
number of H1N1 flu virus going around
and remember the H1N1 flu virus while
it's not you know deadly to everyone it
can be quite severe in some people so we
do want to be on the lookout for and
trying to avoid getting H1N1 if we
can I spoke to Dr schel he was very
generous with his knowledge about anical
cysteine he did acknowledge and I'll
acknowledge again here that it would be
great to get more randomized control
trial data on netal cine but we did talk
about this paper this 1997 paper and he
did mention that he and other clinicians
that are forced to be in the hospital
dealing with patients all through the
winter and all year long they're getting
bombarded with cold and flu exposure all
the time that they meaning he and some
of his colleagues deliberately take
anical cysteine as a preventative to try
and reduce the probability of getting
colds and flu and while we don't want to
make too much of any one study or anic
data which is what we're describing when
I tell you about a physician who told me
this or what I did and experien that I
think it is worth paraphrasing the study
that I mentioned before NAC prevented
the symptomatic forms caused by here
they're talking about the ah1n1
influenza virus quite efficiently since
the large majority of infected subjects
in the placebo group 79% developed
clinically apparent disease versus only
25% in the knat group in other other
words Approximately 80% of people in the
study who did not take an acetylcysteine
got influenza whereas only 25% of the
people who were taking anical cysteine
contracted influenza so that's a fairly
dramatic difference and certainly the
fact that anal cysteine has been shown
to increase glutathione that's its
primary mechanism of action as far as we
know and the fact that increases in
glutathione are generally healthy and
good for us and the fact that anical
cysteine is still available legally over
the counter in the US at least currently
it is some years back as you may have
heard the FDA called for removal of
netal cysteine from over-the-counter
sales that I should point out was based
on the fact that certain supplement
companies were making claims about netal
cine as a treatment for hangover and
making a bunch of other claims for which
there was no real data but either
because the FDA was effective in getting
those companies to cease those claims
Andor because of advocacy groups which
worked very hard to try and keep netline
available for over-the-counter sales as
far as I know at least right up until
prior to recording this episode netal
cysteine is available for sale over the
counter so whether or not you decide to
use netal cysteine as a preventative and
there again the dosage is about 1,200
milligrams per day divided into two
different dosages of 600 milligrams each
or if you decide to take anal cysteine
in the manner that I did which was not
as a preventative but once I had a cold
couldn't fight it off apparently got the
cold decided to take 900 Mig three times
per day avoiding that intake close to
sleep because it did disrupt my sleep if
I took it too close to sleep because of
the way that the mucus would flow so
readily you know essentially I know it
sounds gross but I felt like it was
filling up the back of my throat
so-called postnasal drip but it felt
like post naal waterfall and I decided
to restrict my intake of anical cysteine
to earlier in the day only and of course
there's the third option which is that
you opt to not take anical cysteine
until more randomized control trials are
published or not take an Cal cysteine at
all because you're of the sort that
thinks okay with some sleep a hot shower
a good meal some chicken soup maybe a
little garlic who knows maybe you have
some other tools and techniques that you
like you like that ginger tea lemon Etc
maybe that's all you need and if that's
all you need and that's all you want in
order to deal with a cold or flu be my
guest I certainly am not here to
convince anyone that you have to take a
certain supplement but I did feel like I
would be remiss if I didn't cover what
are generally referred to as the
so-called preventatives and treatments
for colds and flu things like zinc
vitamin D vitamin C we now know that
unfortunately vitamin C gets a you know
probably a D minus or an F at least as
the data stand now but there are these
other things like zinc and potentially
an acetal cysteine that can be
beneficial in shortening the duration of
colds or flu and perhaps even helping us
avoid getting colds or flu all together
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us Us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast if
you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or topics or guests
that you'd like me to consider for the
hubman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments during today's episode
and on many previous episodes of The
hubman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while Ms aren't necessary
for everybody many people derive
tremendous benefit from them for things
like improving sleep for hormone support
and for Focus to learn more about the
supplements discussed on the hubman Lab
podcast please go to live momentus
spelled ous so that's Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I'm hubman lab on all
social media platforms so that's Twitter
now called X Instagram LinkedIn Facebook
and threads and on all of those social
media platforms I discuss science and
science related tools some of which over
overlaps with the content of the hubman
Lab podcast much of which however is
distinct from the content on the hubman
Lab podcast so again it's huberman lab
on all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to the hubman
Lab podcast neural network newsletter
the neural network newsletter is a zeroc
cost monthly newsletter that provides
podcast summaries and what we call
toolkits those toolkits are brief PDFs
that describe protocols for everything
from exercise to deliberate cold
exposure regulating dopamine optimizing
sleep and on and on all the newsletters
are available in full completely free of
cost to sign up you simply go to hubman
lab.com go to the menu tab scroll down
to newsletter and enter your email and I
want to emphasize that we do not share
your email with anybody I'd like to
thank you for today's discussion about
the biology of colds and flu about the
biology of the immune system and how to
avoid and treat colds and flu and last
but certainly not least thank you for
your interest in
science